hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and I'm motivated
today we're gonna get some stuff done so
not sure why I'm so motivated because
it's Monday but we got a good workout in
this morning so maybe that's why I don't
know but we're gonna go back to react
land today we spent some time with PHP
the last few streams and I'm just a
little frustrated with it so I want to
take a break from that and build a react
component doesn't sneeze done so may as
well do it give my mind a little break
from the PHP maybe I come back to it
with a fresh point of view and hopefully
figure it out before we get started I
just want to let you know about a few
other things first I I want to show you
all this GoFundMe campaign that I am I
started and so Charles is a free code
camp editor for a medium publication and
he's trying he was named one of the top
contributors so he's trying to get to
one of these ceremonies slash parties
but he needs some help financially so
I'm gonna put a link to this in the chat
if anybody's interested you know any any
amount of money would help but I think
it'd be awesome if we could help out
Charles in getting there so you know he
needs money for the plane tickets for
you know getting a hotel for food you
know for all that so he'll be coming
from Nigeria so anyway check it out if
you get a chance you can read more about
his story and you know maybe you'll give
a donation or at least
if you're not really in a good place
financially so that's number one number
two I just wanted to give a shout out to
my patrons I haven't talked about it for
a long time but just wanted to remind
everybody that I have this I will link
to it and I'm not gonna talk about this
every stream as I promised before so
maybe once a month or something I'll
mention it but I did want to give a
shout out so thank you so much to Dondre
Oliver dawn and Audrey for for being
patrons so right now the for patrons and
I'm super appreciative of that so thank
you so much and yeah so let's get
started now and enough enough about this
other stuff also if you'll follow me on
some social media you might have seen
I've been working on a react native
project on the side for for balance IO
if anybody be interested in seeing
anything about that the project's open
source so there shouldn't really be a
problem with me live-streaming that on
my I probably do it on my own channel
maybe like on the weekends or at night
or something so let me know if you'd be
interested in seeing that I really like
the project I have a having a lot of fun
working with react native it's mostly
just UI stuff so somebody else was
working back in and somebody else was
doing the design so I'm taking sketch
files and turning them from just the
design files and turning them into
actual react native components so just
thought I'd throw that out there see if
there's any interest and then maybe I'll
do some live streams for that as well so
let me know in the chat or in the
comments below or however else you feel
like getting a hold of me okay let me
get my screens situated cool I spent
less than three minutes on all the other
business now we can get to where
coding let me say what's up to everybody
in the chat oh great we have a almost 60
viewers so welcome everyone especially
if you're new let me give you a little
breakdown we're gonna do 25 minutes of
code and then we'll take a little break
about five minutes and I'll go back to
the live chat answer questions and we'll
go back and forth like that and probably
at least twice we'll go back and forth
like that and then at the end whatever
questions are left over I'll go through
the chat Oh answer all your questions
feel free to add questions at any time
or let me know if I'm doing something
wrong
you know that's don't be shy about that
and oh Shubham says hi Jesse today I
started my career as a web developer
really happy congratulations
congratulations I hope you start your
career off you know really well and you
enjoy it I certainly enjoy what I'm
doing okay so let's get to this code I
guess first thing we should start with
is let me show you the old way we're
displaying this data on the old site and
then we can come up with design ideas
for how we want to display it once we
have the idea in our head about a design
then we'll start doing the coding so let
me start my timer so I can find it
yep there we go
this Poulos Pomodoro timer over here
start it up okay let's see this one
might have it there we go all right so
this is the data that I want to display
with this component that we're building
so we'll have a title for the the
program in general this is for
University and we'll have basically four
four tabs I'll probably keep the tab
idea because I think that that works for
each year right now it's not always like
this so there's going to be some
variations so for here it's freshman
sophomore junior and then they go to a
different school to finish out but
sometimes this this won't be based on on
year so these are going to be variable
and I'd love to figure out how we deal
with this because right now I don't have
an input to make these variables so I'll
deal with that on the con on the backend
side of things but in terms of the UI it
won't really matter for today and then
within each tab will have two columns
there are two sections and then we'll
have courses beneath them now these look
like their links but they're actually
not I'm not sure why they show up as
links here they just link back to the
same page so it's a bit misleading on
the current site don't I don't really
know why they it was built like this so
that's what we want now we do have this
link to view all course descriptions and
this link actually doesn't take you to
course descriptions either so it on
sometimes it does and sometimes it takes
you the current page so currently it's
not really the best user experience so
that's all the data that we'll have now
I'd like to figure out what's a better
way that matches our design
that that would work Oh Michael asked if
we're gonna do an grow up today yeah we
could do then go out let me let me grab
my terminal and start that up
it's been a while since I've done in
grok I remember how I did that all right
sweet I think I remember it reporter
beyond 3000 well we will be on 3,000
once I started so let's start this up
young starts is that it
nope Johann dev I'm working on different
projects and sometimes it's yarn dev and
sometimes it's yarn start so I I'm
getting them confused now okay so if
you're not familiar with n drop this is
gonna let you all view what's locally
running on my machine and you'll be able
to see the the changes and the updates
as they happen so I just need to get
this started here I'll pull this over so
y'all can see what I'm doing so here's n
grog and there's a free version of this
so if you're interested in using this
you know check it out just google and
rock and gr okay and you should come up
so oops and rock a CTEP should be 8080
or 3000 I mean 3000 there we go
all right so let me give you I can't
remember which one's it if both of these
worked or not so I'll just paste both
links in here the HTTP and the HTTP link
so area I see some of you are connecting
cool
Wow
Elon Musk is here in the chat so welcome
big fan of your work
just joking I'm sure it's not really a
lie musk okay let's let's get rid of
some of these tabs I don't need and I
will yet here all right this is what we
want to look at so let me go to I think
we have the pharmacy page working so we
can see both pages side by side oh wow
right now I have nothing so this is the
page that that program would go on and I
have no information right now so let's
try to find a page that actually has
information maybe maybe the English page
No
education well that image is huge may
need to do something about that because
that's really big right now okay so
here's the data that we're getting in
now and we just having a big list let's
go back here and see alright so we are
going with the material design kind of
look for everything so usually when you
see material design stuff the tabs
aren't down the side the tabs are on the
top so we may end up one with something
on the top and we are using material UI
so let's check out material you I and
I'm gonna so let's check out the tabs
because we may be able to use some of
the stuff from the tabs and I'll paste
that in the chat as well so y'all can
check it out if you want so we may be
able to use some of this as kind of the
basis for our component and that'll take
care of a lot of the you just switching
back and forth so we don't really have
to think through all that which is cool
the one thing I'm concerned about is
with all these tabs we're gonna have
four tabs if we put four tabs across the
top depending on what these labels are
that might be too much I mean we could
try to cut it down so I mean we don't
really need to use a year here we could
say freshman sophomore junior we could
even switch it up and say year one year
two year three year four I mean that's
possible so I mean yeah I guess let's
just assume that we can cut this down to
be maybe like six
characters I think that might be doable
to do for across let's see how this
looks when we shrink the screen all
right at some point you just scroll okay
I'm alright with that
normally I don't like horizontal
scrolling but in this case it it would
actually fit with what's done with
material material design okay so
hopefully we can avoid that
maybe with adjusting padding and things
like that alright but that looks good
I'd say that's a good start alright so
let's assume for now and we'll build
this out and see how it looks and then
we may change it but let's assume for
now that we're going to use these tabs
up top to represent you know these then
really this this layout here where we
have first semester second semester I I
don't think that's that's bad I think
that's an okay layout the thing that I
worry about is on a mobile mobile screen
what's gonna happen so like this is what
happens right now right it well two
things happen right so actually that's
better than I thought I assumed it was
going to break the layout and we'd have
a horizontal scroll okay I actually I
really like how that stacks I really do
like how that stacks and I'm not sure if
we want to do an accordion here
accordion style menu
we'll see how it looks so here's the
plan and then after I tell you what the
plan is here I'll check the chat to see
if anybody has any objections or other
ideas
so we'll do we'll start with the tabs up
top for each of the years and then we'll
do this look where it's side-by-side on
large screens on smaller screens it
stacks in here and then depending on how
these tabs look on mobile we may switch
up to an accordion style on mobile just
on mobile only
I think the accordion style would not
look as good on a desktop so I'd like to
stick with with the tabs if we can but
we'll see how it looks and to start out
with I'm not gonna worry about pulling
data from anywhere we're just gonna hard
code some of this data probably what
I'll do is I'll just make an object an
array of objects for all this stuff and
we'll pull it in just within our
component like I'm not gonna I think
that'll be faster than trying to mess
with getting this data which right now
we actually we can't get this data right
now because I don't have I don't have it
set up to be able to get repeater fields
from WordPress through graph QL so
that's that's what we're working on the
last couple streams and it's not
finished yet we could potentially if if
we can't figure out how to do it through
a prio we could end up getting that just
through the REST API but I'd rather not
make to API calls on the page if I don't
have to but that's that's kind of a
back-up plan that could buy us some time
we can still launch the site and it
would work and then we could figure it
out later
all right so let me check the chat
before we start definitely want to see
what input you all have see so I'm
skimming through I'm gonna skip over any
questions for now I'm just gonna see if
there's anything
any advice for what we're doing right
now
our heart should say why is there 17
pixel padding on the body it looks weird
see on the homepage we got weird stuff
going on on the homepage
I'm not sure what I should I'm not sure
what you're saying with the homepage
John says you can maybe change the prop
value of the tab title values based on
media queries like oh okay okay yeah so
John's saying that if we need to we may
be able to change what the titles are
for the tabs depending on the screen
size so on larger screens we would have
longer more descriptive titles on a
smaller screen suite or shorter titles
all right I'm gonna think about that
I'll probably I'm gonna try to get away
with just really short titles and then
if my boss or someone really insists
that we have more descriptive titles
then I think that's a good plan William
says so this is an ongoing project you
have been working on yeah we've been
working on it for since like December
January something like that so yeah this
this is a real project I'm doing for my
full-time job here at a university so
yes so this is not exactly a tutorial
this is what my work is so you're gonna
see me make mistakes and we're gonna
make decisions here for this project
during the stream and and this is a real
project all right well let's get to it
let's get to the code so first things
first let's make this component so we'll
go to let's go to this faculty let's go
to this faculty j/s page first if you
want to see this code you can go to the
github repo that's linked in the
description of this video and check out
the code it's all up to date
everything's open source so you can do
what you want with it but what I like to
do when I design a new component is
first I'm just going to build it out
within
Paige that's going to be in and then
once we get it to a point we're happy
with it then I can I'll pull it out put
it in a different a whole different file
it's just kind of nicer to work with in
one file at first okay
so all right so here's where we have the
the content is coming in and we have all
the content being pulled in as a big
chunk of HTML that's gonna change so
we're already starting to break chunks
out of here
so this chunk now we're breaking out as
that section that's that we saw that's
that list of of courses so we'll be
putting this section below so let's
check out what code we need automatics
for left and right buttons will
automatically be presented on desktop
and hit it on mobile
I think we can go with these views for
larger views we definitely want to use
the scrollable tabs so let's grab these
we want to get tab and tabs and it looks
like they're getting app bar as well but
I wonder if we can do this without that
let's see if we can do without it and
let's see what else we need that should
be it and that's all we need right now
so we'll grab these and we'll import
them so if you're not familiar with
react there might be a lot of stuff
that's new here feel free to ask
questions I'll do my best to explain so
what we're doing now is we're importing
this these components so they're just
JavaScript files we're importing those
JavaScript files into this file so that
we can use them there so we say what
we're going to name it and then we say
how to get it right this is the file
path so we're from now we're going to
refer to all the code in this file as
tabs and all the code in this file is
tab ok and these are reacted components
so we can go down here and we may as
well just copy and paste the code that
they have save us some time we're going
to copy and paste this into here
and we're gonna wrap this in a div I
know now there is I believe a way to do
this without having to wrap things in
divs but I can't remember the syntax for
it so we're gonna wrap things and divs
and while I'm again okay
I think it's just indentation stuff yeah
here's what we need let's go back here
and grab our state where's the state
there it is
okay so it's gonna use state in react to
so we're gonna use state to determine
which tab we're on and we may as well
copy this as well so this is
destructuring and i see how it lets us
know i have to type in this state all
the time when we want to call something
that's in state so right here under
render we're gonna put that in and now
we shouldn't have this line let me save
and see if I still have that line
that's we constant state
that's weird alright well this should
work now so I'm just gonna go with it
okay Nikki saying I think this version
of neck supports the empty tags as
fragments camp posts here YouTube blocks
it's just an empty tag just removed if
okay
the Michael Patterson said it's it's
react dot fragment tag I believe okay
cool let's try it so down here actually
let me see
and he got put this in the wrong spot
yeah let me pull this out cuz I don't
think I think I can just put this here
for now anyway
yeah we're not actually getting any data
yet so I'm not gonna mess with that
right now I'll just put it here and then
we don't have to worry about it at all
okay
oh we need the this dot handle change
that's important so we're gonna grab
this so we need a function to change the
state whenever we click on a new tab
right so now whenever a tab is clicked
on is we're gonna call this set state
value right so we're gonna change value
to a different number right each of the
tabs now are numbered so that's how
we're gonna know which content to
display okay so we have our tabs and
labels and then where's our content here
we go oh I see how they did it so they
have this tab container up here in a
function interesting
alright that'll go be what we get into
next for now the timer is almost up so
let me go back to the chat answer
questions for about five minutes and
then then we'll come back
add in some content and then see what it
looks like a short break
alright I'm gonna scroll up to the top
of the chat now and scroll down through
get to as many questions as I can
it's
okay Michael had had said definitely put
year one so we're talking about what's
what labels to use our tabs so it says
because of people changing majors
mid-career okay that that makes sense so
to say software you know freshman
sophomore junior senior year it might
not work for everybody right it
technically you could be a sophomore and
then change to a different program and
you're really going to be your one in
that program so I do like that idea
Benny says how do the accordions play
with mobile devices I would think if
there's a lot of info on the tab but we
have pain to scroll on a mobile device
yeah so there are a couple issues I've
noticed with using accordions on mobile
devices so that well sometimes it can be
a little like janky when you try to open
and shut the accordion
depending on how you how you do it so
the accordion that I've used before with
materialised CSS which is not react
based it is a little bit janky I don't
know that's that's been probably a year
or two ago that I've used that so it may
be fixed now but it wasn't the animation
just was not smooth so I've done
accordions and react just really basic
accordions with no no real animation and
they're fine on mobile but you're right
about the scrolling so you open it up
have a lot of content you got to keep
scrolling scrolling scrolling you do
have the option to then you know close
that you know but potentially if you
open it read the way all the way through
then you come into the next one you
don't want have to scroll a back up I
mean it's possible you could make it so
that once you click on that next section
of the accordion menu the first one
closes so you'd never have more than one
open at once so that can help keep the
page a little bit shorter
yeah but I definitely you know I
understand you know the the accordion is
not it's not always the best choice for
for mobile if you're not sure what we're
talking about with the accordion menu
this is
so when you have these little kind of
drop-down things here that's sometimes
called an accordion
M Verma MV mo coding not sure how that
you want that pronounced says please
create apps with react native all right
cool yeah I'd I mean I don't know if you
were here earlier but I mentioned I'm
doing a side project with react native
and if anyone's interested I may do some
streams on my channel for that so the
link to my channel is in the description
so if anybody wants you go to my channel
if you subscribe and turn on
notifications you should get notified
anytime I I live stream so maybe I'll
start streaming that that project that
react native project okay Michael says I
can't remember the link to get to the
department you're working on and rock
slash education goes to the old page
that's weird do you mean like if you're
on end rock and then you type slash
education it goes to this page like the
the main website did we have to do it a
different way I can't remember
okay
alright it looks like there's discussion
about f1 also Formula One racing is that
it alright so I'm gonna skip over that
you're welcome to discuss that in the
chat but I'm not gonna read it up
alright cool so I got actually got
through everything if I miss your
question just put it in there again and
I'll see it the next time around let's
start up our next 25 minutes timer and
now we're gonna get this component
working so it should show up below here
is where we'll see it I don't think I've
saved it yet so we're not seeing it yet
[Music]
good night son I'd say yeah let's save
it and see what we get nothing yeah that
is it
Oh No I know why I'm looking in the
wrong component we're not in faculty
we're on we're in major okay let me get
the right page up here let's close out
some stuff because I have too many
things open
okay
major all right so let's just get rid of
this stuff I add it over there and I
can't put it pull these out put them
here and the query actually not I think
about it we do we should put this inside
the query component because at some
point we hopefully will be getting the
data from graph QL
if not we can move this but for now
let's put it in here and let's try What
did he say I could do an empty is this
what you are talking about with the
shorthand for the react fragments let me
know if that's the way to do it or not I
guess I can just look it up it's not let
me get this copied over and then I'll
just look up the syntax because I don't
think we've done anything with fragments
weight is the global X still in there oh
no I can't believe it's still in there I
every time I've seen it I tried to take
it out but that was just something hard
should put in there for testing so keep
forgetting to take it out all right so
let's grab these two things and then
that one and we'll be finished getting
everything out of here there we go
oh yeah and now I'm just gonna back out
all this stuff there we go okay
alright let's just check this fragment
syntax
okay fragments fragments
fragment component there we go tackle
cool
all right so that should work
all right let's check Oh property value
of null for what 30
where I miss
it's
all right anybody see what the issue is
I probably should double-check this to
make sure we got everything that we
needed
all right so pulling these that's good
we didn't use this yet we're not using
prop types we don't need this root style
right yeah we're not using that here
let's a button we have the state we have
the handle change are we even bringing
any props no
all right we have everything maybe maybe
I don't have the latest version of next
so maybe it doesn't support this so
let's just throw in a div here just to
see if that makes a difference
mm obscurities
okay so it wasn't that so I guess I'll
go back to what we had before
oh okay it says John says is it not
necessary to import a fragment from
reactant using the empty tags I don't
know
okay
all right so we don't need to
specifically import fragment as harsh
it's pointing out in the chat because it
it comes in with react when we a just
import reacts up here or we bring it
really brought it yeah up here there
yeah
all right let me paste in the rest of of
what we're supposed to have
because Siri will just paste in a couple
of these
maybe it's looking for these I don't
know that doesn't really make any sense
she Michael says roll back and had one
thing at a time yeah actually that's a
good idea instead of adding things let's
take away things
let's get rid of a little bit just so
that we have less to deal with let's
take the tabs out
can I be property value of no is this
this state
alright let's just take this out
all right what am i doing do I have the
style in the wrong plate or the state in
the wrong place maybe that's it no I
don't
why isn't it recognizing this state
Michael said I may comment them out yeah
I guess that would have been easier
what the heck
so it's just not it's not recognizing
that there's a value can't read property
value of you know so when I try to go
get this state it's saying that state is
null
all right so the error message
there's more close up of the air message
so so can tree property value of null so
I'm trying to look at the property value
of state of this state so for some
reason it's saying state is null
and I'm wondering why why does it say
state is no I may not maybe a copy and
paste thing all right Hudson
try console logging this state which I'm
assuming it's not going to be able to
find stable let's see
yeah
I don't know what happened we just
decided to work all right but we've got
all kind of weirdness going on here too
okay so we now have stayed
why do we have this get rid of that and
whoa all right so I'm gonna just go with
a div here because when I don't do the
div and I try to do the fragment it
keeps inserting all this stuff so maybe
that's just I don't know maybe that's
just my editor and the way I have it set
up but I'm okay with just using div it
shouldn't mess up anything all right so
now yeah all right so now we don't have
that weirdness going on but here we have
our our tabs great we have our tabs took
way longer than I thought to just get
these tabs working but sometimes that's
how it is okay now that we have our tabs
we can put some content here that
correspond to those tabs so let's just
grab a few of these
we will paste them down here below the
tabs and let's add another tag and this
change item to year your for I may
change these two numerals we'll just see
on the space they take up and I guess I
can try to put yeah let's some D
structure that value again others copy
it
okay
for now let's just change this see what
we have already up here we pulling in
anything no all right for now I'm just
going to change this to the div and
it'll just display this okay
there we go so now you see we click on
these tabs and we get the data changing
here so awesome so that works just like
we wanted to actually doesn't take up
that much space let's shrink it up a bit
Gobbo zoomed in here area yeah so if we
get it kind of smaller we will have this
scroll here okay I can handle that for
now all right so now we need a little
bit of structure for this part of it and
then we'll also work on we will work on
this right we we don't really want it
looks like this is getting centered or
something we don't really want that so
we need to fix that too but first things
first let's get the data in there and
see how it looks and then we can work on
styling it a bit more all right and
about three minutes we'll go back to the
chat and check out what's going on there
so I think we'll go with
let's see what we have here in material
UI in terms of less to be needless see
what the list look like yeah I don't
think we really need to go with a list
like this
so we can probably just go with basic
like you oli
all right so for now
and so I'll just build this out right
here so we'll need to
this will be nice one
we'll just do it like this five classes
[Music]
what's the is there something for an
unordered list that's like a list header
I can't remember if there is a tag like
that let me know that was probably
better to use for accessibility than
just creating an Li and putting a style
on it to make it bold you know what we
should put this in a grid yeah let's
check out how we're using grid elsewhere
oops that's my timer let's take a short
break I'll go over some questions now on
the live chat and then we'll finish up
just one part of this component with
just some some testing data just so we
could see what it will look like and
then we'll probably finish up the stream
after that I'm going to try to find out
where I left off and then answer
questions from there
okay MV ARMA coding says and Verma
coding anyway let me know I'm supposed
to say that says can you use material UI
with react native apps and as far as I
know the answer to that is no it looks
like we've got some other answers for
that as well Harshit says you can shine
ativ base also says it's always a good
idea to look up an awesome list for the
stack you're using on mpg says what best
performance between using regular CSS
style or inline react CSS style as a way
to styling
I'm not exactly sure I mean I would
guess usually regular CSS is more
performant than anything you can do in
JavaScript but I'm I don't have any
numbers or anything to say like how much
more it is that's if I had to guess
that's what I would say our should says
performance wise inline styles are the
best but it doesn't give you any major
feature like media queries etc nowadays
we style components solution like
emotion style components for rendering
react styling yeah there's a lot more
solutions for that let me reread this
cuz Regulus is just over in Lion react
CSS though as a reactivated styling okay
yeah I could see that the reason I was
thinking the inline react style would
require more JavaScript is because
there's JavaScript happening in the
background to apply those Styles in line
but I mean like for instance in this app
it would be server-side rendered most
likely cached and then served as HTML to
the user or potentially if we're doing
the client-side routing it would still
be cached in our our service workers so
in that case I guess it's gonna seem
like regular inline HTML you know CSS
styles to the user so yeah the inline
would be faster so anytime you're not
importing an extra file that's going to
be faster
but usually I don't usually have found
like there are the difference in that is
going to be so small like milliseconds
right it's it's not going to be a huge
performance increase maybe there are
some circumstances where it would be so
I guess I just wouldn't I don't worry
that much about that because it's not
really a big difference
Julito says shouldn't state be assigned
inside a constructor
I'm not sure we can do state like this
I remember listen that they're used to
at one point you used to have to do
state differently but this way to do
state actually I think is the preferred
way
okay Nietzsche said he's using the
babble plug-in transform class property
so the Declaration of state outside the
constructor is valid okay
I remember a while a while back and one
of the projects we had a big debate
about this and looked up whether or not
the way we're doing state here is the
way we should do it and I can't remember
all the details all I remember is that
after much debate in research we
concluded that this was the way we were
gonna do state for these projects it's
Sonique Jesus so what fixed it honestly
I don't know what fixed it the only
thing I did was I did a refresh I opened
up to have tools and i refresh the page
that's it I don't think I changed
anything in here so I'm not really sure
what happened but it works now
Benny says sorry I wasn't here for the
babble stuff oh don't worry about that
we've done it
honestly we set that up like a year ago
for a project and then just kept copying
the config over for all our future
projects so I don't even I didn't even
remember that we were using Babel to get
that to work honestly and and I either
set it up or I merged the PR that did
set it up and somebody else did it so
either way I still don't even remember
and I should alright okay I didn't get
through everything but let's finish up
and get something on the screen here for
this component that we can look at and
then I'll get back to the chat and
finish up answering any questions that
you have so I figure we'll probably go
maybe like a half hour longer on this
dream depending on how soon we can get
this done and how many questions are in
there so if you have any questions get
them in there you know somewhat soon
before the stream ends all right so
where we at here oh I couldn't find
where my allies were okay so the grid
stuff is where I'm gonna go next I just
want to see
what the syntax is I forget okay
great container spacing and then grid
item I and then we need a great item all
right so our our grid is it's basically
like column classes so if you're
thinking CSS grid that's not really
what's happening here these are
components and material UI well we need
to import them
okay I just say they say having good set
up in your editor for doing react or
really any type of coding is save you a
lot of time like having an auto
highlight things when I forget to import
them or it's really helpful otherwise
you know before I had this stuff you
know I would have forgotten to import
that I would have tried to run it I
would have got an error best-case
scenario I would have remembered
immediately I had to imported you know
otherwise I probably would have gone
through debugging tried to remove stuff
only to realize that I forgot to import
that so it takes you know it takes a few
minutes to set up but it'll definitely
save you a lot of time in the long term
alright so we've got this grid here this
grid item and I'll explain how the grid
works in just a second so right now what
we're saying is we have these two grid
items and we want each one to take up 12
columns right in the screen so we the
system's based on 12 so this means full
width we don't really want them to be
full with all the time so let's say we
want them to be full width if it's extra
small but if the screen is let's say
medium and up we want them to be 6 so we
wanted to take up half the screen right
so let's put six in here I think this
will do it we want it to do okay so
we're gonna save that we're gonna go
over and we should get okay so it's
showing us now they're stacked like that
obviously it's not how I want to style
I'm not worried about that right now
what should have happened is once it
gets larger it should have went to six
so I did something wrong oh you know
what it's probably MD and not just em
and the there we go so we have our
columns that are taking up 50% of the
width and then once we get to a smaller
screen it goes down like that we
actually we could probably keep it in
the columns for longer so let's drop
this down instead of medium screens
let's say small oh I don't know how I
accidentally pasted that in there okay
so this still works
we'll have to see let's see how small we
can get down with this okay so as long
as we don't really have the course names
getting really long I mean they can
always wrap down on the next line that
would be okay this should work okay and
then it would be like that for each one
I'm not gonna copy and paste each one of
these what's gonna happen though is we
would pull in this data and it would
we'd iterate over each piece of data so
most likely each
each tab or I'm sorry yeah each tab so
each year would be its own object in an
array of objects so we would loop over
that and for each loop it would add
another tab you sign went through the
loop and it would also add another one
of these divs here and then within that
it would show us that we would have our
sections but we'd also loop over and put
these allies in for each class right so
we wouldn't actually have all this
markup you know taking up a ton of space
right yeah we just loop through it and
keep adding this you know
programmatically you would just be added
right so that's why I'm not gonna copy
and paste all this out if it looks right
now and it works on one it'll be it'll
look the same on the other ones I was I
was thinking of like making that
structure that array of objects and
testing it out but I don't think I'm
gonna do that because we've already have
you know coming up on an hour and 15
minutes of streaming so I'm not gonna do
that right now basically it would be
something trying to give an example
where we've already done that in this
project I can't think of it right now
but we would use map right so we would
we must do array dot map and then inside
that map function that's where we would
do all of our all of our assignments
here and then each one of these these
classes would be another dot map inside
of it and so we just have to make sure
we structure our data in the right way
to be able to do this easily with dot
map okay so
let's I'm gonna submit this this stuff
I'm gonna make a commit push it up to
get up so that you all can see all the
code that was added and you can mess
with it and then that way I won't forget
to do it and Michael says didn't we map
in faculty list ah yes yes we did
awesome let's see that yes I don't want
to leave you all hanging here so thank
you Michael so here's what okay so we're
getting faculty data right so we're
grabbing that from graph QL we're
getting the faculty data we're doing dot
map right here okay so we have this is
our return for a react component so we
have this stuff that looks like HTML
okay this is JSX that's what we call it
then if we put our curly brackets here
we can jump back into JavaScript land
and we can write JavaScript so we're now
using this this constant that we've
created up here which is just our data
that we're pulling in from wordpress and
it is an array of objects so we can use
map on arrays and then once we have an
object we can just use our dot notation
for objects right and we can say we want
to get faculty so we've we've assigned
the name faculty to each object in this
array that we're mapping over so we can
say faculty dot node so now we've gone
and do the dot node object and now we're
getting slub we're also getting the
title and the content so now this will
end up in our page in our HTML with all
the content for the zeroeth item in the
faculty data array then it will go to
the number one which is really the sec
item right and it'll get all that data
it'll loop through each one and we'll
get this on the page for each one but
it'll have the unique data of title
content and slug so that's we're going
to do the same thing it'll see slightly
more complicated because we'll have to
have nested maps because we have those
lists so it'll look a bit longer we'll
definitely make it its own component
because we don't want to have one
component that's really huge with all of
that so it'll be its own component but
that's what we'll do in here to clean
this up and then it will allow us to
have all the data will keep our
component components really clean the
data will get pulled in from WordPress
and it's really kind of nice when you
can render so much data with so little
markup in your components but that's the
plan so let me commit this so we're just
gonna do a git add and yarn CM so
normally you would just do a git commit
command after that but we have a special
tool set up here that helps us create a
nice commit message so that's why it's a
little bit different I'm gonna say we're
gonna add a new feature and we'll say
we've add basic
[Music]
had basic tab core scheduled to major
page okay we don't need a longer
description we didn't break anything and
that's by default and I don't think we
had let's double-check and see if we did
have an issue for this I don't think we
did but it's always good to reference it
usually I have the link to this there we
go
also if you would like feel free to take
on any of these issues and submit a pull
request if you need help with that let
me know if activation Oh style sample
program sections actually this is
regarding that so it's not going to
close this issue so here's how we're
gonna we're gonna say I believe if we
put our e and then the issue number it
will be referenced in that issue but it
won't close the issue so this is number
102 102 if we were to put fix and then
the issue number it would automatically
close that issue as well which it's
we're not totally done yet so I'm not
gonna close it yet but now anybody that
looks at that issue will be able to see
that this commit did something that has
to do with that issue
so we have a lot of automated tests that
it's running through and automatic code
formatting so it's gone through all that
it's passed everything and now we can do
a git push and we're still in
development so we still push to the
master branch normally that's not the
best idea like if your your project is
already live usually people set up a
development branch but in this case
master is okay so now all this code is
available on github and let's check out
our issue and we can see here it's been
added here we've referenced this issue
so eighteen seconds ago so this is our
commit and now there's a record of it
within this issue as well so that's
pretty cool
all right okay cool so let me go to the
live chat at this point I'm just gonna
answer questions all the coding stuff is
done we may go back to the code if we
get a question that that references the
code but otherwise it's question time so
if you're not interested in interested
in question-and-answer you know feel
free to leave the the stream now and
thank you so much for watching join us
again for another stream at some point
[Music]
otherwise if you're gonna stick around
please put your question in the chat now
or help answer some questions I
definitely do not know everything and I
rely on your expertise for a lot oh cool
william said the LH tag is the list
header awesome I'm gonna put that I'm
just gonna make a note right here age
I'm gonna put that in there now it's not
gonna show up on github but that'll be a
reminder to me Thank You William in
general if HTML has a solution to
something it's better to use it because
that's going to be better for screen
readers to pick up so instead of as I
said before using in Li just putting the
class of header on it and then styling
that a screen reader won't pick that up
as the header right but it would be able
to explain that this is the header for
this particular list so that's it's
definitely much better for accessibility
that's not all you need to do for
accessibility but it's a great start
Harshit says have you checked out the
new repo for JavaScript AF that we're
constantly maintaining I haven't checked
that out in a while I do get updates on
the activity that happens so I'll need
to check that out and actually are you
sure we need to talk about that because
I think well I'll have to check it out
again but it might be time to do like a
real launch if we're ready for it I'm
okay with doing kind of like the MVP
launcher so a Minimum Viable Product
doing that launch and just kind of
seeing you know what happens as I know
you've been doing a lot of work for it
and yeah just be I'm just interested to
see what kind of response we get if we
officially were to launch it and you
know kind of put the word out there
to
Oh michael says is is LH still supported
okay that's interesting I don't know
maybe we'll have to check that out
trying to find something new these are
so old all right let's go past year
let's just try em D ends article on the
UL to see what can go in there permitted
consonant li element
hmm maybe not
let's check out
yeah so there's nothing on LH in in mdn
okay so I'm not sure about that
okay John Hanson says the proper way to
title a list is to wrap a heading tag
and the UL tag with a section tag okay
let's check this out
all right let's let's put that in
quickly so we're gonna wrap the entire
UL then in the section and the section
tag and then within there let's move
this up and put it here and change this
to like in h3 so John let me know if
this is kind of what you're thinking we
can actually see if this okay
I mean visually that's that's okay I
definitely would style this a bit but I
mean that works
michael said even though i haven't had
any motivation to work on my stuff for
Udacity slash Google in the last five
weeks
I still remember little five weeks so
you haven't had have you not worked on
your stuff for five weeks that's a long
time
see
anyway I think I think we have to try to
find a way to motivate Michael to get
back to coding so everybody throw your
ideas for coding motivation in the chat
now or in the comments to the video so
yeah you gotta get back into it I do
appreciate that you're still watching
the stream though that's cool Benny says
CSS grade is judging you right now
I know but you know what for me it's
like I always want to learn CSS grid but
it seems like every time I start to get
motivated to learn it I do a react
native project and then I have to use
flexbox again so I I just learned more
about flexbox
yeah Mel asked what the name of the tool
was for better formatting commit
messages and Nikki says it's committed
so I just wanted to say that out loud in
case you can't see the live chat right
now that tool is committed in Nietzsche
says you can also use commit lint it's
it's very similar okay cool I haven't
used that but thank you for the
recommendation
you I developer says what is that live
I'd like to take on issues UI developer
if you're talking about the github repo
that I had up on the screen for this
project the link should be in the
description of this video
oh and I see Benny also mentioned that
it's posted in the description thanks
many our heart says let's try commit
lint this time I feel like should we try
it on the next project I'm alright with
that
eruvin says can someone send somebody be
more handsome than Jessie thank you for
that I appreciate that it's always good
for the ego I did shave yesterday which
I hadn't shaved in a while I was getting
pretty scruffy so so might be looking
less scruffy than normal I guess
8-bit engineer says how long have you
been coding with reacts let's see over a
year now so maybe like going on a year
and a half I think
Benny said push the master it looks out
a window waiting for nuclear missile to
launch I suppose I think when you have
like one person working on a project or
a very small team you can get away with
with things that you'd never want to do
on a larger project with a large like
especially distributed team so so yes we
do the push to master Ahmed says how to
get react to work in Visual Studio code
yeah as far as like extensions are
concerned for Visual Studio code a good
way to start out with if you're doing
react is to get the react food-truck
extension and that will install a lot of
react extensions that are very helpful
just be careful about performance if you
start seeing a lot of lag happen then
maybe disable there's one part of react
food-truck I think it's still there it
was when I first came out automatically
told you the size of the packages you're
importing so if you turn that off the
performance is fine but that's how it's
start what's called react food-truck so
just you know google that and install
that and that'll be good to get you
started using react with Visual Studio
code criticized how easy is WordPress
been to integrate into this project to
be honest with you like it we've done
similar things with WordPress before so
it's not that hard to integrate an end
because we're you know we were used to
it part of the biggest issue that we're
having right now is we we can't get some
of the fields we're using the advanced
custom fields plug-in to create what
they call repeater fields and we can't
get that day
right now through graph QL we're using a
plug-in called WP graph QL so we have
not been able to get that data yet we
can get other data with advanced custom
fields but not that data other than that
we've had really no problems that I can
remember so I mean it's it's basically
you're just getting data from an API you
know it so it wouldn't necessarily even
matter if it's WordPress or anything
else where you can get data from as long
as you can get the data and display it
you know it's it works and so the only
tricky parts on the WordPress end are
just making sure that we have the right
post types and field setup and making
that data available but I try to use a
minimal amount of plugins but also
minimize the amount of custom PHP work I
have to do so it's kind of a balance
right now between keeping the plugins
you know definitely I like to keep it
under 10 plugins if I can and we've done
more PHP work than I normally do but we
have a lot of custom post types going on
all right I should says people will love
the news spoiler alert and I will also
set up email so that you can get your
daily dose of Awesome Devon news and
packages that's awesome the arson I'm
excited about the news part of it I
think that was amazing idea that was
your idea right horseshit I want to make
sure you get credit for that that's a
really really good idea I think so in
case y'all don't know we're talking
about a while back I happen to purchase
the domain JavaScript AF and I asked you
all what I should do with it and we've
kind of come up with this website that
pulls together a lot of really awesome
JavaScript repositories from github and
a lot of good news and I don't know what
all features we have active right now so
there's some other features that may be
there like a lot voting on things and
like you can add your own repos so I'm
not sure what features we'll go live
with the official launch but I think
it'll be a cool site I just kind of like
the name I thought it'd be cool to have
that name and since I purchased as a
thought we may as well do something with
it and harsh it and Nicki have done an
amazing job of working on that my
contribution has mainly been just like
paying for hosting um and a little a
little bit of guidance on the on the
project here and there I don't even know
how many pull requests or commits I have
but anyway I would love to be more
involved with the project but most of my
projects now are stuff that I get paid
for I haven't really had time for side
projects
I should said we'll be setting up
kubernetes today awesome Albert says how
long - you're finished with this project
I don't know I really hope soon it the
way the project will go there won't
really be a finished there'll be a
launch date and then I'll probably
continue to work on parts of it and make
it better so some of it will be
optimization for the speed some of it
will be making it easier for content
creators to upload their content through
WordPress so I don't fixing bugs it'll
be yeah but I'll probably move on to
another project and then we'll come back
to this project occasionally when
something comes up
oh cool John says that this this format
is the way to do it so thank you John I
appreciate that getting close to the end
of the chat here so don't delay if you
have a question or comment you'd like to
get in there
I lost my place sorry sometimes it just
autoscrolls down to the bottom and I
have to figure out where I was at okay
Michael says below the UL tag wait so
should should that H tag go below the UL
I'd see Nietzsche says I've never
browsed the web with a screen reader
maybe I should yeah it's been a really
long time since I've attempted to browse
anything with a screen reader but I
think that's a good practice for anyway
for those who don't know a screen reader
is a tool that allows people with vision
impairment who can't see your website
that allows them to have the websites
read out to them and so if your website
is created properly it'll make sense
when it's read out but if you do weird
things with your your markup it'll
confuse the screen reader and then also
the person who is being read to so we
want to make sure that we do the we have
our markup be right be correct so it's
not enough to just have it display
properly visually on the screen and say
all users will never check out the code
well that's not necessarily the case the
screen reader will read through it and
it doesn't matter how you styled it
wheel with CSS you know if if you did
this whole list and you didn't use you
ELLs and how eyes and let's say you just
made it all divs and then styled it to
look like a list screener is not going
to pick up on that being a list so it's
just something to keep in mind that it's
not it's not really obvious if you've
never had to use a screen reader
then he says Jessie can I have you as a
wingman me to be your wingman short oh
okay
the the extension 4 vs code that I was
talking about that uses up a lot of a
lot of RAM or a lot of you know
computing power is called import cost so
if you do load up react food truck and
it still comes with import costs you may
want to disable import cost it's really
cool but it just eats up I remember
the stream kept lagging and we couldn't
figure out why for a long time and then
finally we figured out that it was in
for cost when I used to have it on there
so that's why I don't run it anymore
Deon says Nikki try it meaning try to
use the screen reader it helps to become
a better Arya developer Arya its relates
to accessibility it's like accessibility
standards because you can empathize
better with users who use screen readers
yeah definitely a hundred percent agree
Deon this Vishnu says where can I find
the starter kit to follow the session I
do we have a starting kid really
I'm not sure this project has so many
streams I'm not sure where the best
place to start would be I mean it would
be insane to try to catch up at this
point I would say the best thing is just
to ask a lot of questions when you watch
and we'll try to get you caught up you
know as we can and I'm going to try to
go through the code as much as you can
you can always look back on early
commits to try to get an idea of where
we've come from the link to the repo is
in the description to this video
Benny says jessie graff ql or rest or
both so I really like graph QL better
than rest api's because you get just
what you want and nothing else in terms
of the data so if I had the option use
graph QL I will choose graph QL but rest
api's are still awesome so I'm not
hating on rest api's I just think that
using graph kyo to make one API call get
all the data you need and only the data
you need is definitely better than
having to make multiple API calls to hit
different rest endpoints and then at
each of those calls you're getting back
a bunch of data that you potentially
don't need
okay so harsh it says we're not even
using now right now so you can save
money there or you can keep bait alive
okay so hard [ __ ] so it's cool if I shut
down the now account that would actually
be good because that's like 25 bucks a
month to keep that alive so I mean I
unless there's a really good reason to
keep it like that I mean I'd be alright
with shuttin it down yeah I mean I don't
mind covering the cost for this project
until we can get some sort of like ad
money or funding or something but I mean
25 bucks is 25 bucks right it's being
you better to have it than not
yeah okay there was some talk about what
we're using for the search we are using
REST API for the search because our
graph QL set up with the WP graph KO
plugin can't do what we what we need it
to do so we are using a combination of
the WordPress REST API and WP graph QL
continuances love that domain name thank
you I just I just thought up like I
gotta have it right I don't know what
made me think about it but when I
realized dot AF domain names were a
thing I immediately just searched for
different domain names I can get in
JavaScript was one of the first ones I
searched for and I was like oh it's open
I'm gonna get it without knowing at all
what I was gonna do with it I just
thought I just want to have it Ahmed
said I've been a finished Bo's
fundamental so I'm assuming that's
that's Bo Karns JavaScript fundamental
video series here on the free code camp
YouTube channel says where to go from
there hmm kind of depends on what you
what you want to do have you done the
free code camp curriculum yet because I
mean I I think that would be good to go
through that in terms of video series I
mean depending on what you want to do
you can check out some of the other
things here on the free code camp
channel we've been adding a lot of
series for all different topics recently
this particular series live coding with
Jessie is not really great as a tutorial
but it can be it can be good just to see
what it's like to encounter issues and
work through them and see like how we
set up like a real project and go
through the whole process of testing and
launching it and maintaining things so
yeah so I'm adding there's value in it
as well but not necessarily as a
tutorial
snick Monty says you seem to be a bit
down is everything fine hope everything
as well yeah everything is cool I think
if I seem a bit down it's probably just
because I'm really hungry
right now so I actually feel good other
than being really hungry but I actually
I'm starting to feel really good I've
got on some different medication for my
depression so fYI if you're new to the
channel I do suffer from depression and
some anxiety issues and I've I've done a
I do a combination of therapy and
exercise and medication to try to help
with that and I've recently gotten on
some some different medication that so
I'm on antidepressants but recently I'm
doing a like hormone replacement therapy
and a thyroid medication I just started
that so not sure if it's actually
kicking in yet if it's just placebo
effect but I'm starting to feel better
doctor I went to said you know
potentially if your thyroid levels are
low and your testosterone levels are low
that could also cause depression and
since I've been on the antidepressants
for so many years and I'm still
struggling with depression he thought
it's worth a shot so anyway this is not
official medical advice I'm not a doctor
I'm just letting you know what's going
on in my life and particularly how it
affects my coding so I think that along
with you know working out and you know
getting good sleep is helping right it's
helping I'm not like you know laughing
24/7 and happy all the time but it seems
like I'm doing well so thanks for asking
though
okay harsh it says the documentation for
the UI library is also looking great
have a look
oh cool often yeah I definitely got to
catch up on all that artists [ __ ] I just
there's been so busy since since it's
like vacation and that since I got back
from vacation it's just between this
project and the project for for balance
so busy
okay so Michael criolla saying yeah the
H leaves should go inside the UL all
right let's do it and let's save that
let's check it out
oh okay all right I mean I like that
that it's lined up more and this will
look a lot better once I take away these
right so that'll just in case you're
wondering that's just CSS class of Lists
list type or list style type something
like that and then you just put none I
think it's list-style-type:none in your
CSS and we'll put that on a ul see if it
works and if not we'll put it on the Li
and see if it works
and that'll get rid of that that bullet
point
thanks Michael Nino says is their
library and react it gives you a
customizable carousel probably I don't
know for sure
material you I might have something I
don't remember it they might have
something but yeah I haven't really had
a need for customizable carousel and
react so I don't I don't know for sure
Luco mania sevices what do you think
about having a portfolio website domain
using the new domains such as XYZ I
think it's okay for your portfolio I
mean it's for any website I think it's
good like if you can use your name and
keep it short that's fine you can't
always get like a top-level dot-com name
or something like that so I was really
lucky to get it probably because my name
is just not that common that I have
Jesse Weigel com don't go there it's
terrible but one day I'll fix it up but
yeah I think it would be better to get
the domain name that you want regardless
of whether it's about X Y Z or dot IO or
do whatever you want it to be then to
try to have some weird long name and
have it be a.com
that's just my opinion speaking of like
if I saw somebody's portfolio on a you
know on the resume and I saw the link
I'm way more likely to go to it if it's
just short no matter what the ending is
so that's important to me you know on
the on the side of like if I was
interviewing in for a new developer
position or something but I'm not sure
there might be some other factors that
I'm not seeing
world says hard [ __ ] is the honorary
boss yet
harsh its knowledge of coding is quite
amazing so usually when I should
recommend something I for sure try it
don't always go with it under percent
percent of the time but definitely try
it and most of the time end up going
with it
michael says still 44 out watching after
90 minutes must fear record yeah well we
have 45 now thank you everyone for
sticking around and watching that's
awesome
usually people can't handle the really
long streams we're going up on two hours
almost now so all right when I said it
to people drop down Deon says way to
seize the day with the domain name
thanks John says Jesse's videos give you
the coding bug to try out new things
hear that Michael Creole watch a bunch
and you'll be good to go I hike cool
Benny says thanks one more sub from here
thank you for the subscription I
appreciate that I will stalk you for a
react native CSS grid really shines when
you combine with flexbox one day I will
inject it into react native personally
sweet that'd be awesome
Steven says why depression I had no idea
honestly I I don't know why I don't know
why I've depression
late in my late teenage years it started
and I didn't really know what was going
on I started having panic attacks and
yeah so I've been trying to deal with it
ever since I tried to do it without
medication for a couple years and you
know kind of got worse and so then I
tried with the medication with the
counseling the best thing for me that
helps is stay on a good schedule get
exercise medication counseling all like
together if I can do all those things
consistently together
I usually feel good if I start to slack
off then I feel bad again so yeah but I
like to bring it up because I know some
of you also struggle with it and so I
think it's helpful it kind of be open
about it and I'm in a position where I
can be open about it and not face you
know any kind of social stigma for it
I'm not afraid of being described
against at my job for it or anything
like that so not everybody's in that
position so I figure out you know I may
as well take advantage of it why can't
you know just share share with everybody
Deon says depression is a bummer I need
to get some medication myself yeah and I
mean I'm not like I said I'm not a
doctor so definitely you know check with
your doctor and everything you know
different people have depression for
different reasons and there's different
things going on you know so definitely
just you know get to a doctor you can
trust that can check out and try to try
different things just be patient with it
because it takes a while to figure out
like what medications work and what
dosages work well and you know you got
to give them time to work so it's it's
kind of a long process and sometimes you
have to adjust along the way just
medication it's just the way you're
treating it but it's it's worth it to
try you know just if you're struggling
with that you know don't give up keep
trying even if you can feel good just
for a little while it's worth it michael
says my wife walked in when you're
talking about depression she started
pointing at me and told her she needed
to see see the stuff before me he says
by the way I love that indentation
indicator vs code has that highlights at
what level you are yeah really useful
and since and Jessie you need some
bracket pair colorizer in your life if
you don't have it already yeah you know
what that's been mentioned before I
don't think I have it at least not on
this computer so I'll have to remember
to install that
all right michael says the location of
the header is more about arias like
accessibility than formatting cool I
mean I yeah I think it's a nice bonus
that the formatting happens to look
better in that case to sneak Monty says
me to anxiety and a constant feel of
worthlessness mainly after a traumatic
event that happened two years ago mental
issues are crazy hard to think to deal
with I never had them before the second
year period you know what uh mcmoney if
you haven't already I'd recommend
researching a little bit about PTSD so
post-traumatic stress disorder my wife
had the same issues after she had some
really crazy health issues with the the
birth of our last child so you may be
dealing with that especially if there
was an event that that triggered all
that so look up that and like some of
the treatments and things because that
might be a good way like if you haven't
already like I'm not a doctor or
psychologist or anything I just know
what my wife went through and so it
might be an area you just want to learn
more about
lugo mania 7 says thank you Jessie you
welcome the problem mcmoney says hope
from the bottom of my heart that you
find peace you have helped me a lot to
learn react thank you and and I hope the
same thing for you as well
Jordan asks what I miss uh huh I guess a
lot we've been streaming for over two
hours now so you may want to just go
back and re-watch I don't know that I
could sum everything up right now the
whole world's also said it sounds like
PTSD yeah
Phoenix says finally down to my exams
for this semester hooray congratulations
I hope you did well well wall root what
were you combo come out I'm really sorry
I probably just messed up your name
please let me know how I should
pronounce it but anyway they say what's
your take on progressive Web Apps PWA
you think that it'll replace native apps
I don't know
native apps are so entrenched in
people's lives right now it will take a
while I think it'll take a while so I'm
I mean I don't think they'll be around
forever but it's gonna take a huge shift
like those are less who are developers
and understand them I think are way more
open to them than the average person
who's just like you download an app like
that's that's how it is so it's
definitely going to take if if let's say
Apple and Google on their mobile
operating systems really pushed it it
could happen but if that doesn't happen
I think it's going to be a hard sell
because people generally just continue
to do what they've always done so unless
there's a really good reason for them to
start using progressive web apps more
they're they're gonna stay with what
they have so anyway that's my my kind of
opinion on it and I'm take it for what
it is I'm no expert right
Phoenix says also apparently going
through that stressful period of my life
imposter syndrome existential crisis
feeling like I don't know anything
yep all those are my daily thoughts hang
in there Phoenix I mean I think I think
most of us has been through stuff like
that the imposter syndrome gets better
at least in my case it gets better
really since I started live-streaming my
imposter syndrome has gotten better
because I've laid everything out there
for everyone to see all my code even
some like Mia my personal issues things
like that and people still watch my show
they're still positive about it and so
my fear that people will figure out that
I have no idea what I'm doing has been
proven to be a false a false fear right
so that's helped me to get over that so
I think the more work you do the more
good work you do that you're proud of
and that other people like it will help
you get over that imposter syndrome
Stephen says well Jessie had no idea you
ever had it meaning the depression just
remember your stream led me to my first
front-end programming job so you got
that hashtag hype the stream now I'm
learning react Thank You Stephen
honestly comments like that really do
help a lot in this this stream has
helped me a lot one of the things with
depression is you get depressed like you
don't want to see anybody you just want
to be by yourself and not do anything
and that just makes you more depressed
so me wanting to keep streaming for you
all has helped me to like I have a
community now you know I have you all
that I talk to you know very frequently
and it forces me out of that state of I
don't want to talk to anybody or do
anything you know so and it forced to be
honestly it forces me to act like I'm
not depressed because I don't want to be
active pressure on the stream that's you
know I don't want to spread my
depression right I want to spread
happiness so it's literally I like take
caffeine and try to pump myself up I
listen to upbeat music and I try to act
happy even from not and sometimes just
that acting helps me to feel happier so
I'm always exhausted after I stream
which y'all don't see that but like when
I saw screaming I just sink back in my
chair and just catch my breath right it
takes a lot out of me but I think it's
it's helpful the stream has helped me in
comments like that helped me you all
[Music]
like I feel like we we on it like we
have a relationship right we don't see
each other in person but you know we we
have this connection now and it's real
it's it's important connection so I
don't want to get all emotional on y'all
in the stream but I just want to let you
know that I really appreciate you all
and it definitely helps me not just in
the coding you know but also with the
depression and and everything as well
Phoenix says coding helps me get through
it you have no idea how helpful you are
at this time I feel lucky to have top
loader of your life James the right time
Phoenix I appreciate you saying that I'm
really really happy that I could help
Eva says are we talking about coding or
psychological problems both we normally
just talk about coding but occasionally
we do talk about psychological problems
so if you're not into that right now
that's cool don't worry about it we will
talk about coding like 90% of the time
we talk about coding so it's mainly
coding but if you want to talk about
psychological issues we do too as well
so yeah because I think other things in
life affect coding I mean it's just the
way it is on MTG says when or what kind
of project to use these library for
state management and react like Redux
because I see you're not using it in
this project I'm on a project right now
and sometimes I got confused about using
it or not when I find that I'm passing
props down multiple levels then I
consider using state management if I'm
not doing that I don't worry about it in
general right so if the project isn't
gotten like that big that I need to do
that I just go without it because it's
it's simpler to not use it I have use
Redux before I like Redux it's a little
tricky but yeah so that's that's usually
how I decide whether I want to use state
management library or not
Carlos says hello Jesse hi everyone I'm
late but I managed to get the live feed
hey Carlos how's it going Steven says I
do need to tweet you some of my sites
I've made with the company so you can
see what I'm creating I keep forgetting
to do that up to 39 new sites and six
months of work oh yeah awesome Steven I
definitely want to see those so yeah if
you if you get a chance and remember I
yeah send me those michael says don't
most coders have psychological issues I
don't know I don't really know I think a
lot of people do
so I guess coders would do is do as well
I've never seen anything that said
coders are more likely to have
psychological issues but I don't know
mental Health's a big deal right and
we're learning more about it than we
ever have now so I think it's good to
talk to talk more about it you know it
it's it's gonna help people maybe you
don't realize that they even have issues
maybe realize like hey wow now I know
what's going on with me and and I know
I'm you know I'm not alone in this and
there's ways to treat it so I think it's
I think it's getting better for people
to be able to find help and in different
ways to treat these things yeah Mel says
you just got a new subscriber I have no
idea of your coding skills but you sound
honest that's more than enough for me
thank you I appreciate it
yeah I don't know about my coding skills
either I build things and they work my
boss is happy so that's all I know
whether or not I'm better than anybody
else I don't know and it doesn't really
matter
Carlos says I'm actually a clinical
psychologist so coding and psychological
issues is 100% good for me even if we
talk about anything else it's nice to
hear it's nice to hear you Wow Carlos
that's awesome that's awesome well maybe
we can talk about psychological issues
sometime Carlos as long as you don't
charge me for it since that way I'm just
joking
michael says sorry Jesse didn't mean to
make this a group session oh don't worry
about it
harsh it says kind of scary to listen to
this about the mental issues I'm sorry I
didn't mean to freak anybody out
Stephen says I will say I was really
scared making a career change didn't
trust myself and what I knew it did take
me some time to build that confidence
Carlos is your thing Aloha yeah yeah I
mean it's that's that's how it is
sometimes
career changes and things are huge like
it's huge whoa what were you says is it
advisable to have a side project while
working full-time I'm doing it right now
and I've done it in the past it's just
it's a lot of work if I'm gonna do a
side project I'm working full-time I
need I need to have a really good reason
mostly like I need to be getting paid a
lot because that's a time a lot of time
away from my family and I need to be
able to show something for it like hey
family like we can buy this thing that
you all wanted or go on this vacation or
something because I did this so for me
that's what it needs to be for some
people maybe it's this is my path to a
promotion or getting a job or making the
career change it kind of depends on your
situation but just be aware like when
you put in your regular full day of
coding trying to do anything after that
it's pretty it's tough it's not
impossible but it's difficult and you
could easily get burnt out Edward said
I'm new here what is this broadcasts all
about just really quickly this broadcast
is about me doing my everyday work as a
full full time of front-end developer
and so we do the projects we talk about
them together and I answer questions and
we discuss things so that's kind of what
it's about
and I mess up a lot and we get we go
through it and try to solve the problems
together Stephen says teaching K through
five to full-time
programmer was a big change really scary
move but I don't regret it
Wow I'd say that is definitely a huge
change but I'm glad that you like it you
don't regret it all right we're getting
we're getting to the bottom of the chat
here we just have a few more comments
and I think we'll wrap things up we have
a hello from Ukraine how long will it
take to learn to code as a front-end dev
I can't give you time it depends on like
how many hours a day you have to
dedicate to it what you know already and
like how how easy it is for you to pick
up new concepts so really not sure but
you know as soon as you can convince
somebody that they should pay you to
build a website for them then then your
friend right I mean I don't know there's
different definitions but to me like
once you learn enough to actually build
something of value to somebody and and
get paid for it then at that point your
developer at least a professional
developer in the sense of the word like
a professional is someone who gets paid
to do what they do
Carlos says I have to change from
clinical psychology to programming 100%
I changed from my country to my wife
country so I have to do something else
here it's scary that's how life is and
learning oh okay yeah for sure that it
that you know life is is dealing with
change
Moli it says hi hey how's it going
Edward said I'm from Ukraine - awesome
Carlos's programming is a great asset
for life work in any place on earth
definitely amaura says how long will it
take you to get a master with react how
do you get how do you master Java
scripts as well I don't really know that
that answer is going to be different for
everybody in terms of how long it takes
to master it and when it comes to
programming languages that that change
right that can get updated like at what
point do you really master that can you
master it I think the the right thing to
way look at is I'm always going to learn
more right I'm always gonna strive for
mastery knowing that you may never get
there because there's always new things
to learn nikki says thanks everyone got
to go bye
and go go Belgium for the World Cup
see you later Nikki thanks for watching
thanks for hanging in there for so long
with two hours and 15 minutes now I got
to make sure I don't go past my meeting
haha I didn't think I would even be
close to this running into my meeting
time at 3:00 3:00 p.m. Eastern but now
it's looking like it might Mohit says
please suggest to me some project form
urn stack I don't know if anybody has
project suggestions for mine stack
please let little hit no I don't really
I don't know anything I've stopped my
head probably because I've been
streaming for so long my brain is
starting to get emotional
Stephen says it has taken me a couple
years of JavaScript still not even close
yet but I have a four year old so I only
do about an hour on each day in two
hours each day on the weekend oh cool
cool yeah I totally understand how it is
to try to do coding stuff with kids so I
can definitely sympathize with you their
kids are wonderful they're awesome but
for some reason my almost 2 year old
wants to help me code which means she
bangs on the keyboard and says help that
helped edit so it's really cute but not
easy to code all right I'm at the bottom
of the chat now and I definitely need to
end so I can eat something and get all
my stuff prepared for my 3:00 p.m.
meeting so thank you all so much for
hanging in there for so long and and
helping me out talking with me I know we
had a lot of new people welcome and I'm
gonna be in the office again tomorrow I
have a meeting that I have to go to so
I'll be streaming again from the office
good quality and probably sometime in
the afternoon because I have morning
meetings after noon Eastern Time
so anyway again thank you so much and
I'll see y'all tomorrow
until then I hope you'll have a
wonderful day